c'est dans ce beau site que j'ai dégusté
ce mot un mouton glacée et j'en ai gardé
la laine pour se chauffer manette
soigner sa planète préservez sa part de
sites
les vaches à la laine polluantes ça plus
jamais les tomates classé toute la
semaine les participants des récréations
de l'oulipo joue avec la lange répartis
en petits ateliers encadrés chacun par
un écrivain il travaille selon les
méthodes de l'ouvroir de littérature
potentielle qui consiste à se fixer des
contraintes
avant d'écrire au final ce fait des
pauses c'est que tout le monde peut
écrire et mais c'est pas forcément
facile de trouver le moyen de faire tout
seul
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile ce
souhait trouvait que jean partager les
idées et être un petit peu guidée au
moins au départ pour avoir quelques
aides techniques et écriture qui va
aider des gens qui vont aider des gens à
s'exprimer
les participants de ces ateliers soit
une soixantaine de personnes cette année
ont entre 13 et 80 ans la plupart sont
verrouillés mais d'autres viennent
d'allemagne ou encore d'israël certains
sont novices alors que d'autres
reviennent ici tous les ans ce qui les
rassemble
c'est que tous sont prêts à abandonner
leur ego d'écrivain pour accepter les
règles d'un jeu collectif
ici on a des groupes très bienveillant
et par ailleurs le fait d'écrire avec
des techniques de l'oulipo c'est des
techniques qui sont a contraint de
fortes donc
c'est une contrainte qui libère du
déballage de d'intimité justement ou
d'ego est ce qu'on va commenter ensuite
c'est pas la qualité de ce qu'on est
comme personne ou de ce qu'on a raconté
qui est de l'ordre de l'intimé
si on respecte la contrainte ou non donc
ça ça nous dégage de toute culpabilité à
sion ont tout jeune quand on devient
membre de l'oulipo on le reste quoi
qu'il arrive jusqu'à la fin des temps
même après sa mort mais pour rencontrer
un membre vivant de l'oulipo rien de
plus simple en ce moment jusqu'à
vendredi
ils lisent leurs textes en public chaque
soir vers 18h30 à l'école des beaux-arts